مره اخرى الوزير يطلع لعمل الشيوخي
المصادر الضروريه لجنود نحو العالم بتحقيق
مهامنا وتعزيز الامن الامريكي للقرن
الحادي والعشرين وما بعده
واخيرا يوم الاربعاء
الاساسيه في التعليم رعايه الاطفال
والاجازات والتطور المهني ونحن ملتزم
بالعمل مع المجلس
لهذه الاجراءات
توجه تطبيق التالي
التعليمي رياض الاطفال
والحسابات وزياده الوعي وفوائد الاجازات
وبرامج الاعطاله العائلات
حتى المساعدات الماليه للازواج وزياده
الجهود العلميه اصحاب رخاصه
الجنود الوزير وزاره الدفاع
الصينية جوده حياه في جنودنا وعائلات وسوف
والشركاء لضمان التطبيق الناجح والدعم
المستمر لهذه المبادرات المذكره
والمعلومات الاضافيه موجوده على موقعنا
الالكتروني وبالتالي ساجيب عن اسئلتكم
اني
خصوص ضربات المضاده الولايات المتحده قصفت
ثلاث هجمات او
في السوري منشات مختلفتين هجمتين
وثانيا
الحمايه في القاعده
التي قصفت المسيره الايرانيه حسب فهمنا
كان هنالك
الحمايه هل لكان توضح لنا اذا ما كانت او
اي من الاجهزه هناك فشلت ام كانت غير
عامله هل هنالك حمايه كافيه في تلك
المنطقه الان وكيف تمكنت المسيره من
اختراق اهميه تلك القاعده
اولا وبشكل عام
لاسباب امنيه خاصه بالعمليات وناخذها في
تفاصيلها انواع القدرات قدرات حمايه الذين
في مشاهدنا هذا القول بان ناخذ حمايه
القوات على محمل الجد وساقول وفيما يخص
رادار حسب فهمي هو ذلك صوره جانبيه
ولكن في وجه اي هجمات القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه تقوم بمراجعه لتقييم ما حصلت
اذا كانت هناك خطوه ضروريه يجب ان نقوم
بها ومن السابقه الان تحدثت عن ذلك
متابعه حول
الوضع الحالي
مره ثانيه
تتصاعد الامور هناك ونتوقع المزيد من
هجمات
داخل سوريا بالنسبه للجنود
كما اوضحت صباح اليوم وحوالي الساعه
الثامنه
في الوقت المحلي هناك
عشره صواريخ استهدفت قوات التحالف في شمال
الشرقي سوريا والهجمات
للقوات الامريكيه والتحالف ولا اضرار
بالمشات والمعدات
مره اخرى تركيزنا في سوريا هو على هزيمه
داعش وسيبقى هذا هو تركيزنا نحن لا نسعى
لمواجهه ايراننا ولكن هجمات التي تلقيناها
رسالتها واضحه اننا نقوم بحمايه افرادنا
على العمليه على محمل الجدول سوف نرد بكل
سرعه بشكل حاسم
وبالتالي المسيره من الاصول الايرانيه
والجماعات المستهدفه من قبل الولايات
المتحده هي مرتبطه بالحرس الثوريه
الايراني
لمواطن امريكي قتل وسته اخرون جرحوا انتم
والوزاره وزير الدفاع حلت تحمل المسؤوليه
على ايران نحن نعرف بين هذه الجماعات
مدعومه من قبل ايران فلا شك باللعب دورا
في ضمان ان مثل هذه النشاطات لا تحصل اذا
ايران هي المسؤوله عن وفاه مواطنه امريكيه
ام لا
شك تدعم هذه المجموعات وبالتالي فهي تتحمل
مسؤوليه ضمان عدم مساهمتها في اعدام
الاستقرار والامن ولكنهم مستامرون في فعل
ذلك
الوزاره الدفاع حصل في حوالي
حاطته وعندما قدم احاطته هل كان يعرف
بالهجمات
يجب ان نحيلك الجنرال يجب عن ذلك السؤال
اي نوع من السيارات هذه الايرانيه
وسرعه تحلقها عندما
حلقت باتجاه القاعده وهل في الختام هل
اصطدمت في القاعده ام اطلقت الصواريخ ضد
القاعده
هذه المعلومات ليست المعلومات الكامله عدا
اننا على ثقه كامله هو وفقا لتحلات
الجنائيه والتحيات الاستخباراتيه هيا ان
المسيره من اصول الايرانيه صدمت بالمشاه
ما اطلقت لم تطلق اي اسلحه حسب علمي اذا
قلتم ان رادار كان يعمل وكنتم تتعاقبونها
تحلق بسرعه
عاليه كيف تمكنت من الاصطدام في القاعده
وانتم تقومون هذه القواعد هذه
اصلا خطير بهذا السبب الذين قوات عسكريه
تقوم بعمليات عسكريه في الكلمه
من مثل هذه الجماعات والقياده المركزيه
ستجري تقييما في الهجوم ولكن الحقيقه هي
ان هذه الجماعات المدعومه بالحرس الثوري
للاسف تسببت بقتل امريكي لماذا هنالك خطوط
لاسقاط
الى القاعده مره اخرى تشكيله من الاجراءات
لحمايه افرادنا ولكن هذا المكان اصلا خطير
وسنراجع تفاصيل ما حصل